Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I am going to explain an episode called
“Arkange1” from the British science fiction
series “Black M1rror.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in a labor room of a hospital.
Single mother, Marie Sambrell, lies on the
hospital bed, giving birth to her baby daughter,
Sara.
She happily hugs her.
Cut to three years later.
Marie’s father, Russ, has been helping her
raising Sara.
One morning, we see him trying to feed her
granddaughter.
Marie comes in and offers to take Sara to
the park.
As Sara plays, Marie is distracted talking
to someone else.
Sometime later, she notices that her daughter
is missing.
She calls for her but gets no reply.
The screen goes blank.
Then we see Marie continuing to cry and call
for her daughter in the street when a man
finds her.
Apparently, she had followed a cat out of
the park.
Marie hugs Sara in relief.
A few days later, Marie takes her to a clinic.
She has sign Sara up for a trial of a procedure
called Arkangel.
The doctor invites them in, and quickly injects
Marie’s forehead with a chip.
She then begins explaining to Marie the benefits
of the procedure.
The chip just planted on Sara enables Marie
to monitor her through a tablet whenever she wants.
She can have access to her location at all
times, monitor her vitals like blood pressure
and sugar levels, and also see whatever Sara
sees.
The additional feature of the procedure includes
censoring violent or sexual content that wouldn’t
be appropriate for a child.
However, the procedure is irreversible.
The doctor then changes the channel on the
TV to violent gunfire.
She enables the ‘censoring’ feature, which
blurs the TV from Sara’s point of view.
The same thing happens when Sara sees things
that scare her.
At home, Russ is not happy about the procedure,
but Marie dismisses him.
For the first few days, they have fun playing
hide and seek using the tablet.
Marie always enables the censor when Sara
walks by the neighbor’s scary dog, so she
won’t be afraid.
Ever since, Marie has been monitoring every
move Sara makes.
One day when she is at work, the tablet starts
to beep because Sara’s cortisol level is
high, suggesting that she is stressed.
Marie quickly checks it, and sees Ross having
a seizure.
She runs to help her father and saves him.
It is now six years later.
Ross has passed away.
Marie and Sara are the only ones living in
the house.
That day, they pay a visit to Ross’s grave.
Marie still always monitors Sara.
As Marie cries grieving her father’s death,
her face is blurred to Sara, as it is parent
advisory content.
Sara still cannot see the neighbour’s dog.
She walks to her school where a group of her
friends watch violent videos on their tablet.
Sara asks them to describe it to her.
All of her friends know that she is special.
One of them named Trick tries to explain the
video to her.
When she asks him how blood looks like, he
describes it as red juice.
The system also censors Trick’s cursing,
hence Sara only hears a muffled noise.
That day at home, Sara draws a man bleeding
through his head.
As she completes the drawing, the system blurs
the blood.
Frustrated, she sharpens a pencil and stabs
her finger with it.
As it starts to bleed, the system blurs it
too.
She puts the blood on her face to at least
feel it.
Just then, the tablet starts to beep, suggesting
that Sara is stressed.
Marie quickly rushes to her room to see Sara
repeatedly stabbing her palm.
The following day, she takes Sara to a therapist.
He shows her a picture of two people fighting,
but Sara doesn’t recognize what they are doing.
Marie assumes that she has autism, but the
doctor tells her that it is probably the result
of her whole life being censored.
He then mentions that the Arkangel wasn’t
launched nationwide because of the same reason.
Since the implant cannot be removed, he suggests
Marie get rid of the parental unit.
Marie feels guilty for being the reason her
daughter is different.
That day, she returns home and turns off all
the censor features of the tablet.
She then hides it in the kitchen cabinet.
She tells Sara about the system being off
during breakfast.
However, Sara is a little skeptical because
she has never been without her mom’s supervision.
She walks out and is startled to see the neighbor’s
dog bark at her for the first time.
Scared, she tries to cross the road and is
almost hit by a car.
She reaches school to see her friend, Trick,
fighting a boy.
She can see his busted lips for the first
time.
Trick is happy that she can finally see everything
and takes the opportunity to show her sexual
contents and violent videos.
The following day, Marie sees Sara off to
school, then keeps the tablet in the attic.
Sara gets more accustomed to the neighbor’s
dog and quickly runs when she sees it.
A lot of time passes.
Sara is now fifteen and is fully accustomed
to life without Marie’s supervision.
She even makes friends with the neighbor’s
dog.
That day, she is with her friend, Meryl, at
school when they encounter Trick.
He is all grown up now.
Trick and Sara seem to like each other.
He invites the girls to a bonfire beside the
lake.
They accept the invitation and decide to lie
to their parents about going to a girl’s
movie night.
When Sara reaches home, she tells Marie the
same.
She doesn’t question Sara further.
In fact, Marie too is going out with her boyfriend
at night.
The group of friends is now by the lake.
As it turns out, Trick is a typical drug junkie
now.
He passes Sara a blunt and she accepts it.
Meanwhile, Marie is back from her date and
calls Sara while returning home.
However, the call directly goes to voice mail.
Worried, she calls Sara’s friend; her mom
picks it up and informs her that the girls
were never there.
She calls her repeatedly, but Sara doesn’t
pick up.
With no other choice left, she brings out
the tablet from the attic.
She finally sees that Sara’s location is
beside a lake, two miles away.
Marie then opens the cam and is horrified
to see her daughter having sex with Trick.
She quickly turns the tablet off.
Back at the lake, Sara and Trick chat while
making out.
A knock on the door startles them.
It is Meryl telling Sara that her mom has
found out about them sneaking out.
The girls then rush home in Trick’s van.
When Sara is home, she apologizes to Marie
for being late.
Marie doesn’t confront her either.
The following day, Sara leaves for school.
Marie brings the tablet to work with her that
day.
Sara and Trick are together after school when
she asks him about the drugs he sells.
Trick tells Sara that those are not for her,
but she insists on looking at one.
Then, we see him trying to teach Sara how
people usually take drugs, but Sara insists
on trying some.
Trick reluctantly agrees.
Back home, the tablet starts to ring, suggesting
that Sara is stressed.
Marie opens it again to see that it is a narcotic
alert.
She is then horrified to see Sara snorting
coke.
Marie loses her control and throws the tablet.
She gets on her computer and uses reverse
search to find out Trick’s name and address.
The following day, she goes to Trick’s job
and threatens him to stay away from Sara.
She also shows him the footage of them having
sex.
Trick is terrified.
That night, he gets several calls from Sara,
but doesn’t pick them.
Sara is distressed.
The following night, as Sara texts Trick to
talk to her, Marie watches everything from the tablet.
The next day, she goes to confront Trick.
Because of fear of her mother, he tells her
that he doesn’t want her anymore.
Marie again watches everything unfold from
the tablet.
At breakfast, she crushes a birth control
pill and puts it in Sara’s smoothie.
Sara doesn’t feel good the whole day and
even runs out of the class to vomit.
She goes to the doctor later who tells her
that the vomiting is because of an emergency
contraception pill.
Sara is shocked and realizes that her mother
gave her the pill because she had only had
a glass of smoothie that day.
She rushes home and goes through the kitchen
cabinets, but doesn’t find anything.
Then, she looks through the bin, and finds
an empty box of contraceptive pills.
She runs to her mom’s room and finds the
tablet behind her pillow.
Looking through it, she finally realizes that
Marie has been monitoring her all along.
Hurt by her mother’s betrayal and invasion
of her privacy, she decides to run away.
Sara quickly packs all her belongings.
But just then, Marie arrives at the house.
She finds the trashed kitchen and goes to
her room to see that Sara has found the tablet.
When she opens it, Marie sees herself.
Sara is standing behind her.
Agitated, she snatches the tablet from her
and tries to close it.
But she mistakenly turns the censor on.
While in a fight, she hits her mother with
the tablet several times, not seeing the damage
she is causing.
When the filter turns off, she sees Marie
with several cuts and bruises lying unconscious
on the floor.
She quickly takes her bags and runs away.
Sometime later, we see an injured Marie gain
consciousness and run to look for Sara.
She goes out to the street and cries calling
for her daughter as she did at the beginning
of the movie.
She still tries to use the tablet to look
for her, but it is destroyed.
The movie ends as we see Sara hitchhike into
a truck.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.